I'm in the eastern section of Tokyo and
people here love their vending machines
what is Pocari sweat that's a terrible
name for a drink a little bit salty like
sweat curry sweat would you like some
Pocari sweat it tastes just like what it
sounds like oh they're running away
I made them run away into traffic this
is like a canned egg of some kind yeah
this is a bug it's an electric bug
there's no rhyme or reason to any of
this hey what's going on here
each one has different dirty message
dirty message was about adult video
actor Oh an adult video actor yes he
he's not good it says we have no idea
what's in this box this is fascinating
it's about a porno actor and it says
he's not good at what he does yeah he
didn't do only one type oh he can only
do it one time what kind of box is it
this is insanity Oh what is this cookies
cookies cookies
kid's cookies why would anyone buy this
I'm in the neighborhood known as
Harajuku here in Tokyo this is the
center of something called kawaii style
it means cute style think hello kitty
and I'm here with Sebastian who's gonna
help me learn how to dress in this
kawaii style do you think this guy can
do it am i good young for this yeah
looks good you're good right
this is kawaii style this is a style how
are you Spence
yes and they dress like this every day
all the time yeah well I think you both
looked amazing but I feel like I just
ate six pounds of Skittles and then took
acid something will translate that for
you later on okay and it still won't
make sense
[Music]
maybe it's like a disk one something
like this little bit Chico oh you that
means that let's go that means you like
it miss what is she that good okay you
like that good
okay this is a dog that's a dog yeah how
about you good dog yeah okay I knew that
that was no yes so Oh what do you think
so good so good yes
Wow is there a law against me dressing
like a 14 year old girl
what about what else you're a what
48 you're 48 yes you're kidding
you look so young yeah maybe it's the
plastic bowtie I don't know you look
like a Pacific Rim Jewish Willy Wonka
[Laughter]
here we have nice hats yep you're
frightening me really frightening
Sebastian what's going on here what's
what is this this is a vinyl by no musk
vinyl it looks like a sex mask for
second yeah kind of this is fondle you
know yes I know bondage this might be
too much
you know I just realized we should do we
should all go rob a cute bank right what
color do you call that fear for your
hair what color is that choice blue
turquoise blue yes okay I'm getting a
plutonium 25 plutonium don't cheer
cutonium is very dangerous she's most
upbeat person I have met in my entire
life I don't if you heard but I had to
put down my cat yep well they say the
media or should strike earth sometime in
the next day or two and that'll be the
end of civilization as we know it tell
them I'm sorry I made him cry well I've
been dressing this way for a long time
and it's time for me to become kawaii
don't you think
[Music]
I see I was told everyone would be
dressed like this I'm the only one gomen
nasai go gomen nasai machi guy ping
magic eye
she'll be scarred for life okay for her
therapy
you
[Applause]